the Joe Rogan experience Wow Connor talk
there's a open bet boy Mayweather
applying for mm a lot licensed wants six
to eight months to Train he's screwed
this is a in my opinion this is a 40%
proposition which means it's 40% likely
that he might actually do this the
reason why he might do this is because I
think they will give him an ungodly sum
of money I mean an ungodly sum and I
think they should I think that if the
UFC can talk Floyd Mayweather into going
into an MMA ring first of all they
should give him everything they can get
their greasy paws on to get him to fight
Connor an MMA fight just say look we can
give you CM Punk will give you CM Punk
for half a half a bill half a billion
this is a lot of money but you can go
through that in five years instead how
about we give you Conor McGregor for a
full Billie and we'll give you six to
eight months to practice jiu-jitsu six
six to eight months to just figure out
how you're gonna get [ __ ] up he
wouldn't just be screwed that's like
that's unfair to like four people that
have been screwed you would need a way
more way more outrageous example it's
not just getting screwed what he's he
would like someone said it should be a
thousand to one that's not high enough
it's not high enough
if Conor McGregor was gonna fight Floyd
Mayweather
in MMA it is as close to 100% as
anything ever gets ever because if you
think Floyd is all of a sudden going to
become this [ __ ] one punch destroyer
like John the Beast Mugabi in the 1980s
or whatever the [ __ ] that was if you
think that's gonna happen out of nowhere
you're crazy that's not what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen is he's
probably gonna punch Conor that face a
couple of times it's probably gonna suck
but Conor is gonna get a hold of them
and then he's gonna be like a baby and
if that doesn't happen he'll kick
Floyd's legs out from under him
he'll kick his legs sideways he'll
kick them from the outside or kick them
from the inside he'll stay way the [ __ ]
away from any sort of a range before he
can punch him it'll be a completely
alien range for Floyd and every time
Floyd goes in front kick to the stomach
boom front kick to the stomach boom
front kick to the stomach how many of
those can you take ok boom inside leg
kick boom outside leg kick he's laughing
at you now now he's talking [ __ ] you
realize you got to get past those legs
you can try to close the distance boom
spinning back kick to the liver [ __ ]
what are you gonna do now what do you do
now you're gonna be picked apart until
he decides to take you to the ground and
cut your face open with elbows how about
that how about he pins your right arm
down with his left shin gets on top of
you and just starts smashing the edge of
the elbow into your eye sockets into
your nose cuts across your forehead
slices you open like a [ __ ] melon you
don't have a chance no one has a chance
that hasn't had a long history of
grappling and getting kicked it's like
you're a regular boxer is like
especially the best ever like Floyd it's
phenomenal at what he does but if you
put takedowns and kicks into that it
changes everything changes everything
he'd be [ __ ] I wonder if he's done any
training at all well I know these talked
to Tyron Woodley and tyron woodley was
apparently willing to help him prepare
that would be very interesting cuz
Woodley's had some issues with Conor I
don't think he's gonna fight Conor
though I think if he does choose to
fight MMA I really believe the move is
the correct move is he fight someone
like CM Punk cuz with CM you got a guy
who's he's been training in MMA for a
long time now it's been a few years not
a long time but a few years now he had
one MMA fight in the UFC but was very
overmatched it really wasn't fair like
for him didn't make that kid I mean it's
just the difference between the two of
them you know Mickie Gaul is a real
professional elite fighter I mean he can
beat really good guys and he's just not
in that world like CM Punk's a 40 year
old guy who is a professional
entertainer who is basically a big
but he knows enough where you'd we would
bet money on him he knows enough for you
like imagine if CM Punk who is a big guy
he cuts down to 170 in compared to Floyd
Floyd's fought it like I think he fought
it started us career I want to say 130
135 what go to Floyd Mayweather's
beginning fights see what but at the
very least he's definitely fought at 145
as a grown man he's fought at 155
see I'm Punk's way bigger he's just a
way bigger guy so if he could figure out
a way to get to fight to the ground and
like lock in something simple like a
guillotine if he has a good guillotine
that's what I would say if I was gonna
work with a guy like that I would say
you're gonna come we're gonna
concentrate on one [ __ ] choke I'm
gonna get that thing down to like laser
beam perfect precision so just if you
just spent all your time doing like one
marcelo garcia style choke just figure
it out one good choke one where you know
that if you get that chin down you tuck
it in and slap it on one choke whatever
it is that you know how to close that
[ __ ] up 90% of the time i'm people
that know how to defend there's a lot of
guys that have that like maybe they'd
have a triangle or maybe they have a
head in our head and arm chokes a good
one that's a good one to master some
guys just finished most people with like
that one choke if he just had that and
just got floyd to the ground i just got
his neck it's super super possible that
he could win like it's possible that he
could win but it's also possible the
floyd can win that's what makes that
interesting because floyd is still one
of the best boxers of all time if not
the best still a [ __ ] elite athlete
still light speed in in there like with
its footwork and its movement his head
movement he's so fast he's gonna be way
faster in CM punk so if CM punk can't
get ahold of him and every time he moves
in he gets his face lit up a lot pop up
with a dude who's fastest [ __ ] with six
ounce clubs now he's got four ounce
gloves on very little padding and he's
catching you right on the champ back and
you can't do [ __ ] about it you're trying
to close the distance and he stutter
step in and move it in front of you and
CM Punk is not like the best kicker in
the world
I'll buy it I'll buy it but you have to
fight me whether if he'd come come say
my maid I would just no no you mean
you'd have to fight her Connor Connor no
no you wouldn't you don't think so Oh
he'd get killed he would literally get
killed I know but they get smashed she
ends up doing him ma you know everyone
wants to see it though that's what
everybody wants to see for sure Rhonda
and him fight yeah yeah um I don't think
he's gonna do it I don't think he's
gonna fight McGregor ever in MMA but I
think he might fight CM Punk I believe
that I believe that could happen I know
they're not even that's not even like
official talk but I really believe that
can happen it sounds crazy I know but
the whole thing sounds crazy it sounds
crazy to think that he could fight
anybody in MMA that he would be willing
to do it he must know something because
he could just go into boxing he must
know that he's his time as a boxer is
just done he who cares you have enough
money
[Applause]